uh just we're gonna have to dig our way
out of it
and that's just the way football works
sometimes and um
just gotta tighten some things up i'm
glad we came back
defense made a big play for us for the
end of half and that got us
you know ignited a little bit and then
we made some plays in the third quarter
made
some good plays in the fourth quarter so
finishing started the game
well finish the game well we just that
middle part we got to
got to figure out how to play 60 minutes
well hey tom obviously
the downfield passing opened up in the
second half it seemed like he was mostly
dumped off there in the first half when
he were able to get people
anything changers that somebody did
defensively that set things up for you
in the second half
yeah we got to do a good job you know
forcing them to cover everything and
you know the passing got a little
compressed and then you know we made
some plays down the field and that
opened some things up so
it's a uh you got to make them defend
everything and uh
that was just uh you know a good way for
us to do some things there in the second
half we have to keep doing it
we're 25 of the way through so it's not
early anymore you know we have a decent
sample size we got to figure out
what we're good at what we're not good
at and keep working to get better
and uh the guys that haven't had much of
a role got to find a way to find a role
for themselves and the guys that have
got to keep improving it increasing it
and
i i know we have a lot of playmakers out
there but we got to continue to gain
trust in one another
become more dependable and consistent
and ultimately play you know well for 60
minutes and see what it looks like
if we can do that
it played poorly and uh it was just a
show of character
what the second half was going to show i
can honestly say had this been last year
we
got our ass beat by 20. this team has a
ton of character
and and playmakers and we started making
plays and
you can see when we don't beat ourselves
we're going to be a tough team to beat
you know why didn't he just say i really
really have no regard for jameis winston
as a quarterback because that's what
bruce arians was saying because that's
the big difference
between last year and this year and yeah
last year
they wouldn't have come back from 17
points down this year
they have a guy who never gives up he
came back from 28 3 down in the super
bowl for crying out loud
and chris this is where a guy like tom
brady even at age 43 is a difference
maker for a team
because he's going to make everyone in
the locker room and
everyone in the building and everyone
connected to the franchise in any way
shape or form believe
that anything can be accomplished no
matter how far behind they fall yeah
no you're right all i mean everything
you said there i mean first off he's
still throwing the ball
at a very high level as we see i mean
pushing the ball down the field making
plays that way
and yeah he might not be the guy that
can carry a football team anymore
but he's a guy that can maximize when
you have a
a team set up the way tampa is set up
which is
very talented offensive line getting
better we're seeing running back coming
along
we know the wide receivers and tight end
player like
you know redonkulously good okay the
defensive line is one of the best in
football
so he's maxim he's really perfect for
down there he really is
and then what they're doing on the
offensive side of the ball like byron
leftwich bruce arians
i think they deserve a lot of credit i
mean mike you heard me during the game
yesterday i'm sure because
the one thing i see i see a lot of tom
brady in the offense i do a lot of the
new england
spread them out short passes and that's
the formula they've kind of used the
last few weeks
spread them out short passes get tom in
her rhythm
then bring in two tight ends maybe three
get the defense to have to play kind of
a simple oh we might have to stop the
run
type of defense and we can't blitz
because we're worried about that
that's usually how defenses play those
formations
and then that's when bruce arians and
byron leftwich take their shots with
brady
knowing oh we can keep a tight end and
get an extra guy to block
this will keep brady comfortable and
feeling good in the pocket and give him
that aggressive frame of mind and i
think that's slowly what
i'm seeing a little bit in tampa as
brady is starting to get
more and more aggressive the things that
i had issues with him last year
you know now i think he's starting to go
wait okay they're protecting me
i understand what you know the offensive
game plan is every week
and it's leading to him making some big
plays down the field to oj howard and of
course mike evans and company
five touchdown passes yesterday and he
shrugged off the pick six and it's funny
chris because
we were watching the games i'm here in
west virginia but i've got a live link
with everyone in connecticut and you
were talking about how tom brady knows
the seattle beaters
the plays that can beat that cover three
defense and that's something he's done
time and again
and then oops it's a pick six to the
chargers
out route he should just quit throwing
the out routes like that that's where he
gets into trouble with the pick sixes
but
you know what hey i threw a pick six in
the super bowl right and we came back
and won
that's right so what take a pick six
you're gonna get one
but i'm still gonna take care of
business i mean that that's the value
that's that
that's and here we are they lost to the
saints week one
and the the sky was falling and you know
we we we see that every year
you lose week one and the sky is falling
well for the bucks for the colts and the
browns the sky
didn't fall they're all undefeated since
week one and the buccaneers are looking
pretty damn good right now
and tom brady is one of the big reasons
why and and i don't want to take
anything away from mike evans who
got it through an injury and had 120
plus receiving yards
you know they're gonna have to get it
done with o.j howard going forward they
believe he's got a rupture to kill his
tendons so
oh wait we have gronk now whether or not
gronk ever gets back to being the guy he
was is a different story but
you know they just find a way they never
give up they never give in and they find
a way and that was what they were
lacking
last year and they were seven and nine
lacking that line yeah that's right
exactly seven and nine last year where
we all saw talent and we went man i mean
they could get in the playoffs and
you know that they can overwhelm you
with their defensive line when they have
sue
vitaveya jpp shaquille barrett and
they'll even bring vernon goldston in
sometimes just to get five one-on-ones
and they will one of those matchups is
gonna win or dominate
you can guarantee it the linebackers are
special and levante david and devin
white
and then you know we're seeing a young
secondary kind of starting to blossom in
front of us a little bit
too in some ways i mean they're still
living up some big plays but we've seen
them make some plays the last few weeks
too
but you know i you know you talk about
brady the out
routes and things like that uh you know
i'll take it right now
if i'm a tampa fan and i am and a brady
fan and everything like that
they're more dangerous like this keep
pushing the ball around the field tom
you know okay you might throw an
interception but look how much more
dangerous of a quarterback he is this
year as compared to last year
because he's making defenses like he
said in that press conference
defend the whole field he's not looking
for oh where's julian edelman for a
five-yard throw ooh where's the back
he's you know he's got talent around him
and i think he's buying into what he's
seeing
and i think that's really been helping
and as we've talked all along his arm
has not really declined much as we're
all witnessing
he's brady in some ways might be
overrated in chris sims's eyes for a lot
of things but
in criticism's eyes he's very underrated
for some of his physical
tools and his arm is special that way
now can i just say one more thing
to just change the subject just a little
that play call before the half was over
by the chargers was so stupid
they were up 24 to seven the bucks had
one timeout
kneel on the freaking ball and go in
24-7
i mean that's the coach's fault that's
anthony lin's fault
what are you doing they had the bucks on
the ropes and they gave brady the ball
at the five-yard line
to jump start the team and go in feeling
good when they were gonna go in feeling
like crap
that was the dumbest play of the day and
i have to blame the head coach
for not seeing that with a young running
back and quarterback and a team that
only has one timeout
kneel on it move on
yeah i uh i agree with you there and
it's a shame anytime you're up 17 points
in this league
in past years you just assume you're
going to win it's a major disaster if
you lose
what we've seen though this year
especially and i saw a note from the nfl
last night the the patriots by coming
from 17 points behind
they are uh they join
a string that goes back every week of
the season all four weeks there's been a
team that's come from 16 or more
from behind the winning you meant the
bucks but you didn't mean the patriots
right
i mean by the bucks i see tom brady come
on get your crap straight baby's on the
bus
and i think they're patriots but anyway
you
anyway every week this season the team
has been 16 or more points behind and
has come back and won that's never
happened before so
with with all this scoring that we're
seeing now this is one of the byproducts
no lead is safe
and you can't screw around even if
you're up 24 7
at to your point like the chargers were
you got to get into the locker room 24
7 and you better hope you can hold it in
the second half because i have a feeling
even if they wouldn't have given them
the gift at the end of the half
yeah it was going to be close anyways
the patriots are still going to
the brady the brady the brady you're
going to figure out the the tampa bay
he's still going to figure out what to
do the brady nears
i mean yeah no but you're right i i felt
the same way too
you felt like okay even though they're
going 24 7 you just went
well that that could be a big enough
cushion to make this really interesting
in the fourth quarter i i did i did feel
that way as well but when he got the
24-14 you went oh man
i don't know if they're gonna be able to
do that but mike i think the offensive
point you bring up first off
i mean we're seeing it and it's an
offensive year
they have a clear advantage right now
defenses are struggling in
all shapes and forms as far as they're
not as complex right now because i think
it's still
early in the football life of a defense
you're seeing that they didn't get to
practice a whole lot
and then the other thing too with these
comebacks and things
crowd noise crowd noise is making a
difference and it's in
it's it's it's increased the offense's
advantage
because the defensive line in no moment
ever has an advantage anymore in those
moments where we go oh the way teams on
the road and they're down by five or
seven or anything like that
there's just no crowd noise to let the
defensive defense
maybe shut it out do things like that
end the game
uh but yeah it does seem like the teams
with good quarterbacks and high-powered
offenses are
really at an advantage this year that's
got to be a huge factor though think
about the bills up 28.3 and they have no
fans there
last week against rams to clamp down on
the defense and the next thing you know
the rams are head but these scores
they're obscene i love it though this is
what i've been wanting i want the
college football type scores 37-28 31-21
33-25
49-30 i'm not even skipping any i'm
looking at all the numbers here
the only game that stands out there are
two that stand out is not high scoring
rams giants 17-9 colts bears 1911.
every other game both teams were in the
20s
and a lot of them both teams were in the
30s or close to it and that makes for
more exciting football
the chargers have an exciting football
team because they have
a very good quarterback justin herbert
his
statistically he was better than tom
brady yesterday
he completed uh 20 of 25 passes and he
averaged
11.6 yards per attempt which is
ridiculous and here's some of the people
involved in yesterday's
game praising the rookie who looks like
he's got a very bright future
i i told uh anthony after the game i
said you got a great one
you know that that retreat and play that
looked like my homes
where we had an all-out blitz and he
just kept retreating and throwing a dime
down the field
and uh you know for rookies to make
plays like that you know they're special
he was very impressive today and he
played great i mean our defense played
great all year
and uh he hung in there made a lot of
good throws they hit us on some big
plays
we blitzed him a little bit and he just
stood in there and took it he's got
obviously all the abilities got a great
arm
and um moves really well you know the
team believes in him
so he's off to a great start it was uh
prior to last season and he just called
just wanted to reach out
um he wanted to say good luck and and i
returned
the message and just said thanks for for
reaching out and to hear from
a hero like that was was really cool
they kind of blow you away did you
obviously didn't recognize the number
were you
shocked that it was tom brady well he i
think he called me
at uh 4 a.m pacific time so i wasn't up
yet
and so i let it ring and i probably
should have answered it had i known it
was him
[Music]
you know you would think a guy who grew
up in california would be sensitive to
the whole
eastern time pacific time i mean that's
one thing you always factor in i factor
in the people i know in california
even if even if it's a text like i'm not
going to send a text at 7 43 in the
morning to somebody who i know lives in
california because it's 443 unless it's
john gruden not that i would ever text
him
but uh uh or that he would ever accept
it i'm sure i'm blocked on his phone and
everything else
but yeah come on tom come on tom it's a
bad mess with the kid like that it's a
bad move mike he knew what he was doing
he was i don't want to get in a damn
conversation with this kid i got to play
him in week four
i want to make sure i beat his butt i
want to say something nice to him and
encouraging with him
so he called at 4am he goes he won't
answer i won't have to get in a
conversation i'll leave a nice voice
message
he'll hear my voice it's respectful and
then they move on it's perfect move by
tom i
i i well done well done mr brooke
one of the reasons he should be glad
he's not on the patriots he doesn't have
to worry about
crossing paths with justin herbert in
the postseason or as often in the
regular season
as he will as a member of the buccaneers
he'll probably never play justin herbert
again unless they end up
crossing paths in the super bowl but
he's insane between now and the end of
brady's crew oh he's great
and we saw it against the chiefs and
then last week chris
last week it was like what the hell
where's justin herbert what's going on
and then yesterday uh he looked even
better than he did against the chiefs
he did well you just you see the first
off the size of the human being
i think that's the first thing that
always jumps out to me i mean he has
such stature there and
you heard aryans and brady talking about
yeah we tried to blitz them
you know that was after they kind of
they kind of sat back at first and went
i don't know if this guy can kind of
dissect us
and read defenses let's make him do that
and he did that well
and i think then they went okay well
let's change it up here because that's
not working
let's blitz and see if the kid can
handle the blitz and he just as you
could even see in the press conference
there's just not much that faces him
there's not he has just that way about
him you know
life's easy for for justin herbert and
he doesn't seem to ever be panicked
and then yeah they blitz him and like
arian said that's like mahomes type
throws i mean
the two bombs he threw to guyton and
then i can't remember the other one to
johnson down the middle i think believe
but the guyton post corner down in the
end zone i mean that was
that ball must have traveled 60
something yards in the air you know and
then of course
the one bruce aaron is talking about
fading away like that
that is special he can make
game-changing
you know momentum-changing type of
throws
let alone he can do that with his feet
too i mean
from the looks of things just from this
last year i mean burrow justin herbert
have special futures herbert
has a real special future we can't
forget about him because we talk about
burro a lot but
uh yeah i'm really impressed with the
the
just the talent of justin herbert at
this point
and all of that makes me want to see
tua when will we see a ton of iloa who
was
caught between burrow at number one and
herbert at number six two of the fifth
overall pick in the draft and once fitz
magic becomes fits tragic again i think
that's when we'll
see to it hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports